hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my daredevil review for the
rest of the season I just I want to get
into season 2 videos but there's there's
like a whole bunch of stuff that I
haven't talked about from season one yet
just to start with the big news you all
probably heard daredevil has been
renewed for season two they didn't say
exactly when that would premiere but
based on some of the changes they made
behind the scenes in terms of personnel
I think they're gonna try and drop it
next year
logistical II that creates some
interesting issues because of all the
other Netflix series that they're gonna
be premiering next year you know Jessica
Jones Luke Cage iron fist
you know like all those series are gonna
be going on at the same time so I'll
talk more about that after we get
through daredevil season 1 stuff because
my last video ended you know right
around the beginning of episode 5 I'm
just gonna start there and work my way
through the rest of the season so here
we go so episode 5 is like the beginning
of the big you know Claire temple Matt
Murdock romance official romance they'll
probably be on again off again through
season 2 foggy had this really awesome
line where he was like you know Matt
doesn't have girlfriends for longer than
a couple months at a time making it
sound like you know he's gonna have a
new girlfriend every new season just
because new seasons take place over the
course of a couple months I've seen
that's kind of funny
it just like clearing a path for future
romances with Lady bullseye Elektra you
know any other female character they
might bring on the show this is a good
thing I feel like as a character Matt
Murdock works better when he's not like
fused at the hip with another female
character just because he has so much
chemistry with Karen page and you know
who knows what's gonna happen in season
two so it just it works better if he is
not like in a committed monogamous
relationship with Claire temple and I
think she feels the same way too it's
just like I can't have a relationship
with a superhero that doesn't mean
they're gonna stop having sex or
anything like that like though the price
still hook up but the same type of thing
happens on arrow with Oliver Queen's
character you know like season 1 season
2 there were a number of women that he
had temporary relationships with so
daredevil tells Claire his plants to
kill Wilson fists cut the head off the
snake
nice reference to Hydra obviously we
know what happens when you cut the head
off a snake two more rise up in this
place there were really only loose
connections to the rest of the Marvel
Universe in series 1 so season 2 we
might see some more of that I think
they're trying to keep this relatively
self-contained usually when we see those
references it's with logos or company
names that's like the easiest way to do
it
episode 5 is also the episode where they
kind of tee up the the Karen
foggy relationship which really wasn't a
relationship and not something I was a
huge fan of I like the actor playing
foggy but I feel like the story like the
season one to spend a little too much
time with his character foggy and Karen
were trying to solve a mystery that Matt
essentially solved after the first
couple of episodes so it was almost like
they spent half a season wasting time
there are always logistical problems
with with the first season of any show
just because you have to introduce
characters you have to develop them so I
think the reason that they spent so much
time spinning their wheels with foggy
and Karen it's just so they could
explore those characters and you get you
can learn a little bit more about their
motivations there's still a whole lot of
Karen page that we haven't gotten into
that I mentioned in my episode 3 for
video just a whole lot of backstory that
we might see in season 2 speaking of
character development - we also get a
like a deep dive into the Russians
moving into like episode six - where
Matt gets stuck in the warehouse with
that one Russian even though it's very
clear that there are terrible people the
episodes do a very good job of making
them sympathetic take episode six for
example like you start with Matt trying
to save the Russian and him trying to
kill Matt cut to the end of the episode
they get to this place psychologically
where the Russian sacrifices himself so
that Matt can escape through the sewers
I would say you know of all my like
favorite character based episodes that's
my favorite just them inside that
warehouse favorite line hands down was
when Matt said sorry I don't speak
that episode was also the first
time the kingpin and daredevil spoke to
each other I'm just like you we want the
same thing the only difference is I do
what you do on a scale that matters they
did a really good job of addressing
scale you know it's like how can a
street-level hero hope to do as much
good as say like a team of Avengers or
someone with superpowers this will
continue to be a big theme that they'll
develop throughout the rest of the
Netflix series Jessica Jones Luke Cage
iron fist and defenders some of those
people do have special powers and you
know they do get into some mystical
aspects especially with the Mortal Iron
Fist but it's one of the big questions
that daredevil answers you know regular
people can make a difference so moving
into episode 7 territory with stick to
chase the hand this is really I think
like the biggest jumping off point for
season 2 plot lines so for those that
haven't read the daredevil comics stick
is a member of an organization called
the chased they're fighting a war with a
rival organization called the hand Nobu
the character we see Matt fighting later
in episode 9 in the the red ninja outfit
he's a member of the hand they're
different from madam GAO's organization
the hand are Japanese Madame Gao is more
Chinese so the chase gets into like the
more mystical aspects of the daredevil
universe they're the same organization
that trained people like Elektra lady
bullseye even though Elektra later
joined the hand
so whenever Elektra shows up on
daredevil she might be a member of the
hand or she or she might be rogue don't
you just feel like it'd be more fun for
Elektra to enter the series fighting
Matt Murdock rather than as his best
friend so the chaste in the hand do have
you know as a certain measure of
mystical powers in members of the
organization do you know do you have
special abilities it's not really clear
how much the show's gonna get into this
you know because defenders gets into
Doctor Strange territory so you know I
think they'll be like a certain level of
mysticism if not full-blown magic they
might hold that off till they get to
Iron Fist though he's a much more you
know magically based character than
daredevil is and everybody's asking you
know who is that weird tattoo person at
the end of the episode that sticks
talking to that's probably stoned he's
just another member of the chased
organization the other big question is
black sky like who is the black sky
child that they keep referring to
there's a couple options one he's just a
regular inhuman and they'll explain it
that way the same way they explain other
people with special powers - he's the
vessel for the reincarnated soul of a
really powerful hand member like Gorgon
or three he's the vessel for a
full-blown demon that they're going to
raise this is in the comics there was a
brief period where an offshoot of the
hand worshipped a primordial demon
called beast and raised him so so they
could be going to like full-blown demon
territory Han talked about you know
bringing shadows to this world the kind
that you don't want to see so I do think
they're gonna need into mystical
territory so stick making all those
vague comments about war and math being
ready to step through a door when it
opens for him I think that that's that's
exactly where they're going in season
two they do have different show runners
so the new show runners could choose to
take it any direction they want but I
think eventually they're gonna try and
have all these series loop back on each
other so the hand and chase characters
just make it a little easier to loop it
back in on immortal Iron Fist which is
going to be the last series before
defenders
we also have to address the developing
relationship between Vanessa and Wilson
Fisk
Vanessa without a doubt the most
interesting complex female character on
this show I really want to find out
what's going on inside her head in
season two she's not an evil character
but she sees Wilson Fisk all these
things that he's doing and she totally
drinks the kool-aid or at least it seems
like she does like their relationship
seems very genuine I like the way they
start things off too you know she's very
eyes open she knows exactly what she's
getting into she brings a gun to their
private dinner date that scene where
they're watching is like all the
Russians get blown up over town and she
just says good getting rid of the scum
in the city you get the sense that she's
a little bit vicious which is just fun
you know she's not crazy but she doesn't
shy away from the idea of killing people
she's kind of like an older darker
twisted version of Karen Paige
Karen Paige despite her implied you know
mysterious past feels like a very
innocent character so as we move through
the rest of the episodes we see the
slowed decline of Wilson Fisk I know a
lot of people were upset that he seen it
seem like he went down very easy but you
have to remember that this is also like
this season one is the rise of Wilson
Fisk it's not like him starting out as
kingpin usually when you see Wilson Fisk
in the in the cartoons or in the comics
he is full-blown kingpin you know
mastermind what they wanted to do with
Vincent d'Onofrio's version of the
character it is give you a much more
psychological picture at where he's
coming from just as like a contrast to
that I think a good example of just like
a straight-up tried and true black cat
wearing villain is Baron von Strucker
from age of Ultron so even though
Strucker and kingpin both very big
villains in the Marvel Universe he spent
so much more time in kingpins head that
I think he becomes a much more
compelling villain it just it becomes
much easier to sympathize with him which
makes it so much more interesting it's
so much better when there's a villain
that you don't think of as a true
villain I mean at a certain point you
have to root for someone so someone has
to be the biggest protagonist so
obviously the series is called daredevil
it's gonna be about him but that doesn't
mean that you have to provide an overly
simplistic version of kingpin so that
it's easier to identify with the hero
and that final scene of him staring at
the wall that was so much fun you just
you get the idea that when he comes back
it's going to be as a much more fully
realized villain look at this wall and
think about the man that you want to be
truth be told you know I would have been
nice if they'd to spend a little less
time with foggy and a little more time
developing this hand storyline and spent
more time with stick but I think that's
all stuff that they can deal with in
season two if you guys didn't notice the
same stunt person that did Chris Evans
stunts for Captain America Winter
Soldier also did daredevil stunts so
that's why the fighting style in Winter
Soldier and daredevil looks very similar
it's literally the same dude jumping
around kicking people my favorite fight
scene is the one at the end of episode 2
where he goes into the Russians base and
gets the little girl out that was all
done in a single take favorite
improvised weapon was the microwave
throwing the microwave through the door
to take the guy down when you don't have
your Escrima sticks yet you have to make
do with what you can find
my favorite editing in an episode though
was episode 9 where where he was
fighting Nobu and it jumped backwards
and forwards in time and then back to
the fight they kind of did a version of
that during the arrow midseason finale
where Oliver Queen is climbing the
mountain and then ends up fighting
Rachele ghoul but but he keeps jumping
backwards and forwards in time as
awesome as this is it can be a little
disjointed on't pay attention really
closely so that's why you don't see them
editing episodes like this all the time
what about the right costume though I
know a lot of people are saying they
hate it a lot of people say they love it
I think it's a work in progress I think
it's it's really interesting I like the
material I like it way better than the
Ben Affleck costume when Melvin Potter
said that he's still working on he's
like you know this part might stop a
blade this part might stop a bullet I
think that just means that they're gonna
tweak it over time so if you hate the
way it looks now you know don't worry
they'll modify it as the seasons go on
we're entering season four of house of
cards so you know I think there is no
doubt that Netflix will continue to
greenlight seasons of daredevil
hopefully we'll get like five seasons
that'd be amazing I try not to compare
daredevil too much to like a lot of the
other crime drama action series just
because you know the way they shot up
for Netflix is so different than the way
they shoot traditional TV series think
about it this way like when you're
shooting a regular TV show you have to
build in act breaks for commercials they
didn't have to do that with daredevil so
like the way they paced the episode was
way different than say like agents of
shield which airs on ABC what I'm hoping
is is it the success of daredevil well
emboldened Marvel and Netflix to do way
way more stuff like this you know dark
gritty drama in the
tradition of HBO but done you know on a
streaming platform I will say it's a bit
of a nightmare to try and do videos for
13 episodes all at once but it'd be a
really entertaining nightmare I know a
lot of people asking about the other
Netflix series you know now that I'm
kind of working through daredevil stuff
I'm gonna start doing season 2 videos
and I'll start doing some Jessica Jones
eventually - there's still a lot we
don't know about that series yet what
I'm hoping is is that you know by Comic
Con they'll announce Jessica Jones as
being released sometime at the end of
this year there's no confirmation on
that they could hold it to like spring
him next year Charlie Cox did say that
he wants a cameo in Captain America and
that's gonna be a spring movie next year
so it's possible that they could try and
have like some some loose referential
crossover between those series just to
address some of the daredevil season 2
news already so what's gonna happen is
is Stephen tonight the showrunner from
season 1 is departing he can't do season
2 that's only because he has a
scheduling commitment with a film that
he's making the minute they announced
that they were gonna be new show runners
for season 2 everybody freaked out it's
not because he's leaving Marvel or
anything like that it's just because
he's signed on to do another movie and
the dates for that overlap with the
dates where they'd be shooting daredevil
season 2 so he just he doesn't have the
time to do both and he already signed a
contract to do this other movie so he
can't get out of it once they actually
start working on the story and start
shooting episodes though they'll
probably release some news about you
know characters castings new people to
bring on like I said hoping for bull's
eye Elektra a lot more characters tied
to the hand and the chase really don't
be surprised though if Wilson Fisk
spends the entire season inside the
prison like he's still a big villain but
he does everything from inside the
prison that just feels like a really fun
way to do it so even though we have him
already
you know I'm expecting them to bring in
some other big antagonistic character to
be like the big bad of the season even
though Wilson Fisk will always be
Daredevils ultimate villain so what you
guys wait for more daredevil videos if
you haven't already be sure to go out
and see age of Ultron I did a
non-spoilery review you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for
all my other daredevil videos thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you